j'espère que l'assemblée nationale bain
se hisser au niveau de ce moment
historique et reconnaître le génocide
qui vise les ouigours en chinois
reconnaître le génocide des ouigours
cette minorité musulmane turcophone
réprimée par le gouvernement chinois
dans la province du sindh chang c'est ce
qui est demandé aux députés français
pour raphaël glucksmann ça ne fait aucun
doute c'est un génocide et il a fait de
la défense des ouigours son combat de
député européen l'un des premiers
reportages sur cette minorité c'est dans
l'émission géopolis en
1999 déjà on y part la stérilisation et
contrôle des naissances on pratique la
stérilisation forcée sur des centaines
de milliers de nos femmes nos mères et
nos soeurs sont emmenés à l'hôpital de
force pour subir des avortements on
jette des milliers de foetus aux ordures
et stérilisation qui visait les ouigours
et dans do kunis à parme dans leurs
archives et bien est devenu systématique
on est vraiment dans une politique qui
vise à rendre les ouigours d'abord
minoritaires dans leur propre région et
ensuite à les effacer pendant longtemps
le sort des 8 bourg a été passée sous
silence c'est près de dix ans plus tard
en 2008 que les journalistes vont à
nouveau s'y intéresser quand la chine
organise les jeux olympiques d'été à
pékin si le tour de vis est identique
aux tibétains les ouïghours n'ont ni
dalaï lama ni richard geere pour le
faire savoir
ici en chine nous n'avons aucun droit en
tant que oui nous sommes les esclaves de
la chine
par rapport à 2008 on est passé à une
autre étape en fait du contrôle de masse
c'est que finalement des témoignages qui
sont reçues la serait impossible
aujourd'hui le contrôle s'est accrue il
ya des codes barres sur les maisons et
la police peut scanner et voir mais il
ya des gens dans chaque maison est ce qu
ils font la prière est ce qu'ils boivent
de l'alcool est ce qu'ils mangent du
porc donc finalement les interstices de
liberté qui existaient il ya encore
vingt ou trente ans n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
stérilisation forcée surveillance et
puis en 2018 des ong révèle l'existence
de camps de redressement selon les
organisations internationales
un million de musulmans du xinjiang
aurait déjà été internés dans des camps
mais la france ne reconnaît toujours pas
le génocide en cours en février prochain
les jo d'hiver auront lieu à pékin
seront ils un moment de mobilisation
générale pour le peuple ouïghour ce que
nous devons faire c'est essayer de
saisir l'opportunité des jo en martelant
à un message très simple en fait on ne
fait pas la fête à l'ombre des camps de
concentration aucun représentant
officiel aucun début aucun ministre ne
doit aller applaudir ce qui sera une
farce à la gloire de ginn fils
[Musique]